yeah okay so let's continue with the
tutorial
uh
yeah okay
okay
so I will show you how to use the
previous technique in the ayli case I
mean it's a simple extension I will go
I'm not going to show you all the
details details what I really want to
show you is in the second part is in the
second part of the first part of the
tutorial not the second part of the
tutorial so I have way too many slides
what I want to show you is the other
technique that is widely used in the
area which is this idea of using this
hor withd stonome estimator so I
mean and and with that actually I think
I will be happy actually if I managed to
show you all that okay so how do we do
sampling in the a cyclic case so
consider in this case this a cyclic
query you fix a joint tree right so
assume that we have something like that
and and let's use this this relation
here indicat that R subi is a descendant
of R subj in this joint tree right okay
so then as in the previous case if we
can do exact counting we are interested
in this counties quantities W of T which
is the tople T join with the joint of
all the childrens right that's what we
are doing here right we take all R subj
such that not not only children all the
descendants actually sorry you take all
the r subj such that R subj is a
descendant of R sub I and then you do
the joint right exactly like in the
previous case but now we're considering
it treat right and uh we also have this
this quantity here right which is uh if
R subj is a child of R subi we like to
say well here what we are doing is we
are essentially counting all the tables
that we have from R subj right but
considering this is restricted to T
right so we're doing R subj all the
descendant of R subj and we are doing
the joint with this T right what is
important here is that as in the
previous case we are not going to have
this W we're going to replace this by
uppercase W which is going to be an an
an estimation right and you want to have
some properties which are natural
properties and as before you expect this
W to be larger than or equal than to the
previous value we expect this also to to
be true when you consider this
uh predicates where you're considering
children so you are saying if T belongs
to R subi and R subj is a child of R
subi then you should have this this
relationship here you expect w t be
equal to one when when you have a leaf
again the same process when you were
thinking about the last relation in the
joint and uh these are very natural
condition actually you will get
equalities if you are thinking about
this lowercase w but in this case you
are expecting that if you take WT and
you and and you consider the the numbers
that you are going to get for the
children right since when they are doing
the join actually you what you have to
do is to compute the multiplication
right you don't have variables in common
between these R sub K1 and R sub K2
which are not in the in the in the
parent right you just have to combine
this this these tles by doing the
essentially the if you're thinking about
counting the multiplication then you
expect this value WT to be larger than
the values that we have here and also we
have this final condition that is the
same that we have before right you
expect to this W of t r subj be greater
than this W when you evaluated in the in
the semi joint and this W for relation
is just defined as before as the sum of
the W over all the tles so it's a set of
actions like the generalization to what
we have before
and then the procedure is is is as
follows actually it's it's not that
different from before you you will
sample with some probability and reject
with some probability and you will do
this in every in every element of the
tree right so you sample with the
probability that we have before we
reject with some probability and and now
notice that this probability that also
depends on the estimation that we have
for the children right so here we have
R2 and here we have R three right so it
depends on this estimation that we have
here we know this this quantity it's
actually a probability because we know
that this is a smaller or equal than
this value here right and uh as expected
actually actually this should be R2 and
this should be R3 there is a typ of here
right so because here you you are
sampling considering okay I already
sampled this tople R1 I consider the
semi joint how big is that and I compare
with the size of the whole set right and
I reject with probability again as
before proportional to this W of R2
divided by this W of this quantity here
the quantities are not really important
important thing is that when you put all
together you simplify things and you
obtain what you expect right and the
same thing here this is R three and and
and we do this this thing here so
actually when you multiply this thing
okay so sorry so when you want to
compute the probability that the tole is
in the answer you have to consider the
that you have to accept not to reject
right so the probability of accepting
are this one here and when you multiply
all these things you say what what is
the probability of R1 R2 R3 is generated
it's just a multiplication of all these
probabilities here and you immediately
will see that you start simplifying
terms like this one is here this one is
here and at the end what you get is this
wr2 wr3 divided by wr1 and these two are
Liv in this case so these values has to
be equal to one so what you obtain is
one divided by w r one right exactly
what you have before it's just that you
need to consider a process where you are
considering the children's of a note so
it's not different from what we did
before okay just a few words about
sampling in the cyclic case this is not
a I would say satisfactory solution but
it's a solution that could be used in
practice there are better methods
methods so here is you have a join query
right and but that is cyclic and the
proposal here was to split Q into two
queries QA cyclic and Q rest essentially
QA cyclic is it's a query that is a
cyclic QR is a query that that is going
to be cyclic right and what you are
going to do is you're going to use the
algorithm for E cycli queries here and
here what you are going to do is just to
do and and you're going to use an
exhaustive algorithm right you're are
going to do counting actually right so
you have to really solve this question
if you do that you can do you can do
something so assume that the A1 a are
the common attribute between these two
queries right so then you need the an an
an estimation as before I mean let's
call it this m rest the only thing that
we are saying here is okay let's
consider all the possibility for these
common attributes and in this query q
rest let's count the tables where we
have so for every combination we count
how many tables have these values right
and then we compute the maximum right so
this is given giving you a bound on the
number of tles that you can do you can
have in the joint right because here you
are joining this QA CLI with Q rest so
you are saying if I have a tle here with
how many tles can I join this there
right this is going to be a Bound for
that quantity right so and then you do
the sampling and cycling in the same
same the same way right you say okay uh
in order to do the sample use the sample
algorithm for the a cyclic case to
generate a tle in in QA cyclic this you
can do it efficiently then reject with
probability that is going to be uh
proportional to this Q rest semi joint
with T so here you you will have to
compute the answer to this Q rest so
what you expect is that even if the quer
is large hopefully the the the part that
is cly is going to be small right you
hopefully you can divide this into a
query that is large and another one that
is that is small and then you are going
to generate uniform randomly a from this
Q rest again exhaustively you you don't
have an algorithm to do that right um or
an efficient algorithm and and uh and
notice that the tables are generated
efficient sorry uniformly not
efficiently uniformly because the
probability that TT Prime is generated
is the probability that t is generated
times again the probability that t Prime
is generated given that t is generated
and you are going to be in a situation
similar to the previous one right the
probability of T is generate is one
divided by this quantity what we had
before the algorithm for the a
case then you have to accept and the
probability sorry this is the size right
size is missing here is the size of this
Qs semi joint T and and here you have
this ESS which is a
quti is a quantity that doesn't depends
on the uh tles actually so you simplify
these two values here and what you get
is this which is similar to the bounce
that we have before right you are saying
W of R1 times this this this quantity
that we have here okay so it's going to
be uniform generation it's it's it's uh
but with the the the caveat that here
you have to do some or you have to
compute the answer to Qs right since the
split is not unique yeah can you take
it's almost like generating another qu
plan right how do you choose yeah
actually I didn't know that but one of
the Coors of that paper is here and
actually they have some optimization
techniques maybe you can say a bit more
actually about because one of the the
the the the topics actually when when
you're trying to do this thing is how
you choose actually these things yeah
yeah I don't know if you want to say a
bit more I think for cic one we are not
we are not doing a very good job because
yeah the
last sampling over the ones and I think
this one is just for practical uh
implementation we want to transform a
sec one into an a by breaking some
drawing conditions uh yeah I think the
you know how yeah there are many
different choices how to do this uh
transformation I think it quite depends
on the Practical they has said and so if
you take the triangle there are three
ways to do
it
so I mean in this I
don't okay in the paper about one that
join actually there actually they have
some techniques to choose the the right
order actually but it's different from
here it's not that they want to divide
it into queries actually want to sample
in some order I will show you I mean how
how it works actually but here I don't
know actually know you do
that okay
uh okay so let me take tell you a bit
about now estimation of cardinalities
and Aggregates and now is when we are
going to talk about this hor with Thome
operator which I think is a if you want
to learn something from this tutorial
this is one of the important
things okay so one thing is that here
what we want to do actually when we are
doing estimation of cardinal and in
particular of Aggregates when we say
okay we want to compute the sum in this
column and we want to have an estimation
we need to have okay we need to
construct an estimator and and we also
need to think about confidence intervals
right we we like to say okay we know
that with certain probability the answer
is going to be inside this interval
right and when you do that you rely on
on on estimators just I'm going to say
just a few things probably you know all
these things that I'm going to say here
remember that just when we have an
estimator we talk about the bias of
estimator which is the different of the
expected value of the estimator and the
quantity that we want to estimate right
this is the usually thing and in general
we want unbias estimator right we want
this bias to be zero right we want we we
want to have an estimator such that the
expected value of the estimator is the
value that we're trying to estimate the
second property that is very important
is very useful in practice that the the
the estimator is consistent right which
means that it converges in probability
to this uh value of theta actually if
you don't know the definition this I
mean means the following in this
estimator is going to depend on some end
this is usually the case right the
number of of samples that you that you
make right and the larger this nend the
better that the estimator should be and
this is what you are saying here you're
saying that for every Epsilon greater
than zero if you think about the
probability that this estimator actually
minus Theta is greater than this Epsilon
you take this probability and then you
take the limit when n goes to Infinity
this limit has to be zero yeah the first
Thea seems to be a
number yeah this one yeah yeah here both
it's a number yeah it's number I mean
you are converting to this value
actually not to a distribution actually
in this case uh I see
SOA is actually a number no no no no
Theta Theta hat is an estimator and
Theta is a value right okay so then how
can how can the
S ROM variable how that ROM varable
really wanted to concentrate I mean yeah
I mean you are thinking about think term
of distribution distribution that has
only one value right I mean maybe it's
very think this way right so this
probability is it's well defined right
you are thinking about the probability
this is a concrete value and you're
thinking about the probability that this
estimator that you have here minus Theta
is greater than Epsilon right this is
the
definition above
right the bullet explains what the prev
one you mean yeah yeah this one yeah
this one that was saying that what does
it mean for a distribution converts to a
value oh yeah this is okay sorry s we
were talking about this one yeah the
definition of converting probability is
this one here right yeah yeah okay sorry
yeah yeah that was a confusion okay yeah
yeah you have an example of a
consistent biased estimator yeah I mean
something that you could do is like for
example the average right the average is
uh
it's defined like this right and in
general it's going to be unbiased right
but suppose that now you define the the
average whatever like like this for
example yeah this is from one to n right
one to right so if you think about the
the expected value of this guy right
it's going to be like n n minus one
Theta right so this is this is biased
right but it's going to be consistent
right
okay so this is something that you asked
to the to the estimator and in our
particular case not from the work of
from a statistics we will also want this
the Theta to be computable in polinomial
time and actually very efficiently in
right okay so just a few words about
confident intervals so in general what
we want to provide is something like
this right we would like to say that the
probability that Theta is in this
interval here that depends on the value
of the estimator right are two function
f and G and I want this Theta to be in F
of this well the depends on the
estimator right and G I would like this
to be greater than one minus Delta I
write it like this because usually you
say Delta is a small quantity right I
want this probability to be large but
okay in general what you want to have is
something like this right you want to
have that the probability of theta is in
this interval that is the value of your
estimation minus plus some Epsilon that
depends on N you want this value to be
greater or equal than one minus Delta
right this is what you want and a couple
of of comments about what are the
fundamental tools to construct
confidence intervals well the first one
is the central limit theorem that I
assume that you all know um and uh
something to consider there is that the
confid confidence interval depends on
the convergence rate right so uh which
which means that you have an
approximation right of the of the of the
uh
um confidence intervals if you fix a
value n right right so this is something
to consider and there are some like
interesting tools that you could use
actually to not to have this problem
like this very essent theorem actually
which actually gives you a precise bound
of the different with a standard normal
distribution under some assumptions for
the for the variables that you are
considering which are assumptions that
are usually satisfying right and and
this is one tool you would use you get
like larger confidence intervals but you
know that actually that you are you are
you are with the high probability your
estimation is going to be so the value
that you're trying to estimate is going
to be in the confidence interval the
other uh um set of tool that are usually
used here are the concentration
inequalities right chbf Hein uh which
are uh the bounds that are produced are
not approximation I'm not don't depend
on on a conversion conversion rate but
they're looser right usually you produce
like larger intervals but these are
usually very useful tools and uh and in
both cases both for the central limit
theorem and for the uh concentration
inequalities what you want to use is
estimator that have a small variance
right this is is very important actually
because usually the sizes of these
confidence intervals depends on this uh
um variance and let me just give you a
simple example probably you all know
this the CHF inequality I mean this is
the usual way that you write this this
inequality right you you think about the
probability that x minus the expected
value of x is greater or equal than
Epsilon and this is smaller than sorry
this should be an X right right the
variance of x divided by Epsilon squ
right and if you put it in terms of an
of of of an estimator and you say that
Theta hat is an bias estimator of theta
then you can write this this inequality
just this CH inquality as follow you are
saying that the probability that Theta
is in between this Theta hat minus
Epsilon and Theta hat plus Epsilon is
greater or equal than one minus the
variance of this Theta hat divided by
Epsilon squ right so if you want this
probability to be large you need this
value of the the to be small right this
is just a simple observation but this is
what you usually want in practice you
want estimators with a small
variance not
very so in the equation about is a
random variable yeah in the equation and
and E of X is a number yes and the one
below Thea hat is a random variable yeah
but this is also R yeah so so X is hat
yeah and uh and this is what you want to
estimate so you you really need to take
the variance
of this is the is just a random variable
you think of this random varable right
and here you have the expected value of
this Theta half which Isa there should
be variance of X yeah yeah yeah sorry I
said yeah there a Ty should be
X variable and uh the the probability
depends on its variance not on the
variance of your
estimator okay so maybe something I'm
not seeing actually what you want to say
is okay what is the probability that you
the value estimated is in between your I
know exactly what means in the second if
you want to make the second formula
inance of the first one it means that
your Theta is is the expected value of
of theta half yeah that's why I'm saying
that I have an envas
estimator I see yeah so the spected
value this is Thea but you're not
estimating an Unown quantity what you're
really estimating your expected value
yeah you're estimating this value
actually right it's a value that you
don't know then you know that this is
just unbiased so you know that the
expected value is going to be this
unknown right and what you are saying is
that this unknown is going to be in this
interval with this
probability you have I think you may
want to swap the half in a
second but this is the usual way that
you think about the intervals right you
are saying my unknown is in this
interval right yourown
is no your un known is Theta that's what
I'm trying to estimate your estimator is
withinus of the quti you yeah but I mean
why do you need an estimate if you knowa
right yeah I me Theta is a no Theta is
the value that you don't know right yeah
yeah yeah so this is what what that's
the reason why I like to think it this
way right because you saying what is the
probability that this value is in this
interval is greater even than this quti
right it's equivalent but I'm just
saying intuitively it's unknown but what
whatever you're producing
is no no they're equivalent you can you
can switch this to I like to think it in
this way actually right I mean in the
sense you don't need the variance right
for you don't need
the this is
Che because you mentioned before thatf
anding it is important to have small
variance but heing doesn't doesn't use
the variance yeah doesn't use the Vari
yeah it's kind of implicit yeah it's
kind of implicit
actually but H was saying that you want
the interal to be fixed I want to say I
want to be within 10% of the value
theable should should fit that
interval but they equivalent right it's
just a way that I like to think about
this it's like in practice what I'm
going to get is the value of this guy
right and I want to say okay what is the
probability that this guy is in this
interval I can I can produce Theta hat
right I mean I do some sampling I
producing the and I want to say what is
the probability that unnown is in that
interval that's the way that I like to
think about this but you are right
actually another way to think about this
you switch this and you say what is the
probability that hat is in this I mean
in this interval around the unknown B so
I'm close to that b yeah so clear yeah
we happy you're happy
okay okay so let me show you now the uh
this hwi Thome estimator and I will do
it in a very complete work and this is
the work on on one join actually by by
kg and and collaborators right so the
idea is the following suppose that you
want to do uh you want to answer the
following query you have a join but now
you want to compute the sum in over this
attribute D that you have there right
okay so what how can you do this uh you
do the following so suppose that these
are the tles in the relations right and
and and here actually you could say okay
we are going to do let's contract a
graph that I mean conceptually will show
you what we are doing actually so you
are going to put an an edge here if they
have the same value of the if these two
tables can be joined right so what we
are saying here is that R1 of B is equal
to S2 of B right so these two guys can
be joined right so and suppose that we
have this this possible joints in these
relations right and notice that we need
to have an structor like this because AR
two can be joined with these two guys so
they have the same value right in the
attribute B so if this can be joined
with this it has to
be then it can be joined with this one
okay so now what we're going to do here
is just a random walk right so we're
saying okay we're going to select one
tle from R uh with uniform distribution
so we are going to have here this R1
with probabbly 1/3 or one divided by the
side of size of R and then we say okay
we have two edges here right and we have
to pick one and we will do it as a
random walk so we're going to do it with
in this case well with probability one
half right so and suppose that we pick
this one here and then we say okay now
with probability one over three I have
to pick one of the three values here so
I will pick this T4 here right so what I
get is okay the probability of
generating and then this this path here
is equal to 1 divided by 1 over 18 right
is because it's 1/3 * 1 1/2 and time 1/3
right and uh and and this contribute to
the answer to the query in a certain
value and this certain value is D4 of d
right so for this T here actually when
when okay I'm I'm denoting this is a t
right but when you confute The Joint in
the joint in this row you are going to
have as the value in the attribute D
this T4 of d right very simple
okay but there are other tles that you
can or
partial or actually they complete path
actually but they don't represent Tes in
the joint like R1 is1 I I don't have any
value that could be I can use in the
joint that are going to have some
probability in this case so there is a
probability of one six to pick this guy
right because you have 1/3 and then with
probity one half you pick this guy here
but is important now is to say okay
that's okay I I have to I mean I have to
consider this guy but the value that
he's going to add to this sum is going
to be zero right so in this case the
value of this guy is zero so for all the
the path that don't generate the tle
actually you can say the value is zero
okay and then to answer the previous
question actually this or to estimate
this value what you need to do is to do
an estimation based on the path so you
can think about the F you think about
the random variable that assigned to a
path I'm going to use this notation
gamma here this value of gamma right
this value which was the T4 or the value
of the tle in the column D when you have
complete path and when you have a
partial or something that is stopped I
cannot go through the all the relations
actually have value zero so then
actually uh you you you you could use x
as an estimator of the value that we are
trying to compute but this is a a bias
estimator right because because we don't
consider that different path can have
different probability and they can have
quite different probabilities so then
the question is how to transform this x
into an unbias system estimator and the
idea here is very simple is this idea of
hor Thon which is just consider this
consider another random variable which
has this value and just divide by the
probability of the path actually it's
it's very simple the idea so if you do
that actually first notice that what is
going to be the expected value of this
random variable right is going to be the
sum of all I mean all all all all the
path of the probability of generating
that path times the value of the random
variable and the probability of this guy
is this sorry and the value of the
random variable is B of gamma divided by
the probability of this guy then you
simplify these two quantities here and
you obtain exactly what you were
expecting right you sum over all path
this value B of gamma which for the TBL
which are in The Joint you are summing
exactly the the the value in the last
column in column d right and for the
other guys you are you are adding zero
right is that
clear so this is the whole idea of hor
with Thomson actually so you would say I
mean why someone I mean it's a very
simple idea but it works really well
well
actually okay so let me try to formalize
this and show you why this is a cool
idea so well this is this idea from 52
right from a paper of horwood tonsom and
I particularly recommend this book which
is by tonsom not the same tonsum which
is a book just called sampling and it's
a very nice book actually I mean it has
like everything that you need to know
about sampling it's 1912 or2 no 2012 no
2012 2012 yeah a good point actually
2012 yeah okay so the the idea is very
simple yeah suppose that we have a list
of values B1 to BN and we need to
estimate this value the sums of these
values right it could be the average
then you are going to realize that you
can estimate many different things right
so to do this this estimation what we do
is we construct a sample of size n of
element little nend the elements from
from this set here right so we're going
to say we're sampling the element
position three or position five whatever
that has some value right we can do this
with or without replacement is is not a
problem actually
and and suppose that now we have this x
of I which is the number of time times
the element I appears in the sample
right if you are doing it with
replacement could be several times if we
are doing without replacement it could
be zero one right so then
uh Define this p ofi as the expected
value of this variable X xobi and then
what you get immediately is that the and
this is what is called the orbit Thomson
estimator this is an unbiased estimator
for the sum of these values and how do
you construct this unbias estimator you
just say I have to multiply xub by the
value of Vu that is associated to this
element and I have to divide it by the
expected value of the random variable
right very simple and actually if you
think about this this is the same I mean
because just for the ey in the sample
this value could be different from zero
right this is the same as saying I have
to take all the values in the sample and
I have to compute this quantity here and
here is where you have this inverse
waiting that was mentioned yeah in the
you you mentioned this right no no uh we
yeah um that that is very useful
actually when you are doing this
estimations and and notice that here
it's very simple to see that this is
unbiased right respective value of y
which is going to be the respective
value of this quantity by linearity we
know that it's going to be the expected
these are just constant right so it's
going to be the expected value of x y
and and here since we put the spective
value here going to be P sub P subi you
can simplify these things and you're are
going to obtain then the sum from I
equal to 1 to n of this B subi which is
this is to right so you get an estimator
that is unbiased it's a very very simple
idea and it's has been widely used let
me show you just one example so if you
have you sample uniformly with
replacement so in this case the
probability is one divided by n right
then you can think of this variable X Y
as a sum of of just variables let's say
um that have a second index K where this
variable could be one if I is the cas
element sample right so you're saying
okay we're going to do n samples here
right so uh I mean this is a very simple
way to think about this and what it
tells immediately that since these
variables are distributed beri with
probability P these are going to be B
distributed binomial with with
parameters n and p i mean it's a very
simple thing so what I wanted to mention
here is that this then this P of I is
going to be the expected value right the
the the the expected value of a binomial
distribution n p and your are horid
stonome estimator is going to be in this
case this this value here right you have
to replace this P sub I by NP and since
the probability is one divided by this
big n then this is going to be the
estimator right so you're going to say
we have to compute this big n divided by
n and then we have to do this sum sum
here okay so yeah x i is one right no it
it depends on whether it's with or
without replacement right if it is
without rep replacement this will be one
right you just need to compute the sum
of this B but if if it is with
replacement this then this could be
larger than one right so you have to
consider these quantities if it's with
with replacement doesn't bu change as
well no in both cases you're going to
think the the same yeah yeah I mean I
can show you that I mean I I have some
slide a SL about that
yeah okay so it's a very simple idea
actually probably this point you are
thinking why this is
used so often and one of the reason is
the following consider the variance of
this estimator right and to consider the
VAR the variance you are going to need
the the expected value of this x sub I
times x subj right and call this P sub i
j one thing is that this this value does
not is not necessarily equal to the
multiplication of the expected value for
x i times expected value of XJ and the
reason is that this this random variable
are not independent right you know that
X1 plus to X subn is equal to this
little n right because you Computing end
samples right so uh we are not going to
compute this explicitly but what we are
going to get is an expression that looks
like the following when you are
Computing this variance actually you are
Computing the expected value of I Square
minus the expected value of I square
right and this looks like this then
linearity right we replace this sum here
actually and at the end actually you
well linearity you introduce this here
actually and this is the expected value
of x sub I time x sub J we have a
notation for this this is p sub by J
right so you get an expression like this
one so this is an expression that you
can compute if you know the exact
distribution of your the variables that
you are using but the cool thing is the
following in practice something that you
need to do is if you're are going to
provide the confidence interval in
general you need to have an estimation
for the variance right so the question
is how do you do an estimation of this
variant
here
what would be the cool thing to
do what what kind of estimator you would
like to use to estimate the variance the
same the same exactly yeah orbit tonson
again actually it's very simple actually
the only difference that now these are
the values actually that you have to
consider right you use hbit tonson again
so you say okay in this case how do we
estimate we use the same thing again
actually and this is a very cool feature
right you say now my value which is this
B of i j is this quantity that I have
here right and once I have that I know
that the variance is going to be the the
the the sum over all IJ of these
quantities that I have here this is what
I showed before right this is the sorry
this is the variance right the sum over
all these values here that I'm calling B
of i j so what you're are saying is okay
I have this sum here I know how to do
this with hor with Thompson the only
thing that I need to say is okay to to
get an estimate an estimation I need to
have this variable x sub i j that are
defined as the multiplication of x sub I
* X subj and here I have to put the
expected value of x subj which is this P
sub i j right that we have a notation
for that because it's expected value of
the multiplication of these two guys and
then so if you replace if you use the
definition of a high with hold with
someome estimator here you need to put
the the the the variable x y j and here
you need to put the expected value of
this variable and here you have to put
the value that you're trying to compute
right and this is what you get so you
get again a hor bit Thon estim from the
variance actually so you can use it
again right and you get a very simple
estimator and you can do this over and
over again actually so it's it's a it's
a simple idea that can be used and
reused actually to to to do estimation
right okay this is a really good
question um the thing is
that there is no like general theory
tells you how it's going to be the
variance right so what you have to do is
you have to do it Case by case right so
it's not necessarily good uh it's not
necessarily good estimator actually
yeah okay so I have like half an hour uh
so okay so one thing to keep in mind and
to remember about this is like horby
tonson can be considered as a as a
family of estimators right it's really
an idea how to construct estimat that
can be used actually ER in many
different scenarios so this is I suppose
why it's like a nice
idea okay so let me show you one example
of estimation on databases and then I
will move to the to the next topic so uh
let me uh show you this this how to do
something like this like a simple query
I mean with this hor Tome so you have
here the the sum over V of this relation
you want to do this by using sampling uh
so the result of this query will be well
to do the sum of all all toles and and
taking the the attribute B right so this
is what you are doing here and to do
this estimator actually you can do
different things actually in in in
simply r sampling with replacement you
are going to just select tles and and
with some probability so you do
something like well in this case with
uniform probability you generate uniform
random s t r in R then you add R to the
sample and and then you say well this x
of R is going to be the number of times
that tole R appears in the in the sample
very simple right what we saw before
that the expected value of this uh of of
of of of this uh random variable is
going to be n divided by the the size of
the relation and then you get this hor
stome estimator right which is going to
be this the size of the relation divided
by n and you have to consider well this
the samples you have to multiply the
value of this xabar times the value that
you have for this El that's a very
simple thing actually and then you can
compute the variance I'm not going to go
through the details but you get okay I
can show you this you get like
expression like this one actually right
it's a variance that depends essentially
on the size of the database this is the
variance of the values in the database
it's like saying okay I have some values
and I can compute like the average and I
can measure how far are the elements of
the database from that from that average
and it's divided by n it's being reduced
when you have more more samples
okay so any
questions so this one is actually for
the column on which you comp yeah
exactly for the column for the column
actually you take the average and then
you measure how far are you from that
average actually so it depends on that
which makes sense right depends on how
how different are the values that you
have in that
Cod okay so if you want to remember
something from this tutorial I mean this
whole with Thome is really useful as an
idea to construct estimators and and
then well I have okay I'm not going to
go through this whole
thing so all these were ideas where you
were using once and again the horb tons
on different I mean you will have access
to the slide so it's fairly complete
actually okay so what I want to say
there yeah okay so what about other
operators and now let's move and since I
have like 20 minutes to the the
projection actually so the previous
techniques can be easily extended to
consider the selection operator actually
when you do selection the only thing
that is important is that if in the
table you don't satisfy the selection
you have to put value zero to that table
well depending on the application that
you are doing right if you're doing the
summation actually put value zero it's
very simple right uh but the inclusion
of projection is is way more challenging
so let me just say a few words about
about this so what is left is that we
now consider joint selection and
projection so what we're considering is
really conjunctive queries and and our
goal is to show how to do efficient
cardalis estimation for a cly
conjunctive queries and efficiency here
is put like this because we are thinking
about polinomial time actually but
really in practice you want something
much faster right I mean you want
something like linear time yeah
backwards sorry under set semantics
under set semantics yeah yeah that's a
good question actually about under back
semantics where this this this works
extent
yeah okay so uh one thing that is
important to mention here I'm going to
represent this query and I'm going to
give you an intuition of of how this
this thing I mean goes and and uh the
the estimation so one thing is I'm I'm
going to use first s notation so this is
the query that we have before with the
cardinalities this is an a cylic query
right for the for the with the
cardinalities that we were Computing
right and okay so we were the query was
something like this right if we write it
in first the log but now suppose that
you consider something like uh okay so
I'm sorry sorry I'm also changing here
the the relation but I'm using this
notation so now but now suppose that you
move you you you you quantify over some
variables actually and here you want to
return just the X and and W actually X
is is this value that you have here and
W is the value that you have there so
then if you compute the answer to the
query you're going to see that this is
these are the tables in the answer and
the problem that you have now actually
is that if you want to count the number
of answers actually if you think about
the information that they computed here
is not very useful right because I mean
you know that for this tle it appears
six times actually but you know that
this value six that you have is the
value that you have here actually if you
have this value here you don't know how
it's related with the value that you
have there actually it's like okay what
do you do here if some of the variabl
that we use for the joint in particular
the Val in this case is the value of the
variable set actually is not part of the
answer right so it's some value that
somehow was Quantified in actually and
remember that we know that for a queries
the problem of counting the number of
answer is SHP complete we know it's a
difficult problem so this algorithm
cannot work so essentially the the
problem here is that this this these
variables actually the one that I put a
start here they are like Anonymous
actually when you're Computing the
answer once you have the answer to the
query once you know that you have value
for six you don't know which which
values you use to compute this for six
se and this is something actually and
and and and you don't care about this I
mean the answer here is is I mean the
number of T is three and I I should say
three independently of how many
different ways I have to I I have to to
generate this T here
right okay so how do you how do you deal
with this problem and the me main
ingredient here is three aomata so if
you you're going to learn something cool
in this talk is also about three aomata
if you don't know about this is an
extension of word automata which is a
really good representation of of this
conjunctive asly conjunctive queries so
the idea here is the following so I will
show you how this work but first just a
brief introduction to tree automata just
in case I mean you don't know how they
work actually these are automatas that
work over trees right so they work
exactly as a word automata as a neter
final automata you start by assigning
some state to the root right and then
you have some rule that tells you what
are the states that you can assign to
the children right and the rules look
like this you say okay if the state is p
and I'm reading a symbol a then and here
I'm considering
like rank three so I'm saying okay I'm
considering that I have two children and
I'm saying okay the states that I have
to assign to these guys are q and R
right so you will say okay I have to
assign state q here and then I have to
consider the rules that I have for for
this element here and here I'm saying
okay this is a lift so you expect to
find a rule of this form that is saying
okay if I have state q and I'm reading a
b so I don't want to assign any state to
Children this Lambda is the empty string
so what I'm saying okay this could be a
leaf it's okay so this part of the
computation is okay and we can continue
with the other part we were assigning
this state R and we were trying and now
we have to continue here well whatever
is the rule that you have there you have
to continue assigning States
right okay so so what is aom then I mean
in in if defin this way what you're
going to have is just a set of State
just before you're are going to have
some alphabets it's it's fixed it's a
it's a fixed alphabet actually like I'm
saying I'm considering all the trees
where the labels of the nodes could be a
or b you're going to have a set of
initial States this is very important
because you assign this when you say
okay I have to start from some State
they come from I and we are going to
have some transition relation where we
have this rule that tells things like
the when I'm in a in a note with this
with State p and I see an a I have to
assign q and r to the children right
it's a very
simple okay so let me do one example
everyone here knows no okay good
question that alphab repeat but yeah the
trees is uniquely labeled you are given
a tree where you have for each not you
have a label
yeah this is a top down autom yeah this
is a top down autom you can also have
bottom up automat right yeah and and
they are equ so this is this is top down
when I'm going to show you some example
with with is nondeterministic so you can
have for this combination you can have
several of these cripples right and you
can you can think I mean it's not
difficult to Define it bottom up and
they're going to be equivalent right you
can transform one into the other so
nondeterministic top down is equivalent
to nondeterministic bottom up and
deterministic bottom up yes acceptance
condition is that oh I want to say you
tell you in a second what is condition
would that there people here that don't
know deterministic to down is different
yeah yeah yeah okay here we have
deterministic to down and you're going
to see in a second why it's different
yeah it's less expressive than so
transition relation you have one rule
for every state could it be RP c b but
that is not defined like for State can
have only one alphabet or okay so so
it's exactly like a nistic finding aaton
for this combination here I could have
several of these rule that tells me
where how to move actually what I state
to assign if it is empty so for example
if you reach this thing here and you
don't have a rule like this one or you
don't have any rules it means that you
fail right you cannot do anything right
so this is one of the reason to to fail
and you can have several and you have to
pick one like in a non-deterministic
final automat
right yeah okay so let me show you an
example one think is cool so we would
like to uh design a Tre automaton that
is going to check where you have even
number of A's in the tree right this is
what we want to check right even number
of A's okay so we are going to have two
states e for even o for old and you
start from the the starting State should
be e right so we are trying to say in
the whole tree we're going to have an
even number of states and then we have
to start assigning states to the to the
to the uh children and if you think
about how we do this actually what you
are saying here is okay in the whole
tree I want to have an even number of
A's
since I have an A here what it should
happen is that from here I should have
an OD number of A's right and this would
happen if I have an old number of eight
here and an even number of eight here or
the other way around I have an even
number here and an old number here so
how are the rules the rulle should say
something like that so one possible rues
it's if an if I a state a and I'm
reading an a for the children and should
have e o so I'm saying even o and the
other rule which is o e right and here
you get an intuition why what wi was
saying right if if this is deterministic
there is no way to do this actually you
don't know how to guess what you're are
going to assign to the children right
and we continue going going like this
right now we say Okay assigned e and and
and and in this case I say well if I
want to see an even number of of A's and
I'm in a leaf which has label B then
this is okay actually because I'm I'm
I'm I'm seeing Zero a so I have a rule
like this right this rule that tells you
in this case with this LEF it's
everything is okay you you can stop the
computation in that part and we continue
here like now we said we have an we need
to have an old number of A's since you
are reading an a here you should have an
even number of a here and then it could
be both even or both old right and you
continue like that you say oh o and you
say okay I going to have an old here I'm
reading a sorry I'm reading a b so I
need to have an old number here so it
has to be even old or OD even and you
keep going right and and in this case
you are going to accept this this tree
right so the acceptance okay the
acceptance condition is that you have a
a a running I mean an execution where
you can finish
without having this problem that you you
you don't have a transition for some
State actually for some combination
right of course you could uh have
guessed in the wrong way like I could
have say even even which is not the case
here and what is going to happen is that
okay when you you get here actually
you're going to say even but you are not
going to have this rule the rule that
say if I have even and I am in a in a
leaf I'm going to I'm going to allow
that so this is not going to be a rule
in your in your uh tree automata so you
are going to fail here and the acceptant
condition is that you accept the tree if
there is one execution that accepts the
tree the usual thing
right okay so tree automat are a okay I
will show you in a second why it's a
good way to represent a cc conjunctive
queries is sorry
you this is not complete that if you had
the other way of that if you had odd
number of a here and even number of on
this side then it could
not fail yeah what I'm saying is yeah
what it was saying is that okay this was
a a successful execution right the
running which successful uh but but what
I was saying is that for this tree you
could have some runs that are not
successful right so for example if I was
guessing e here right but that's not the
problem right I mean in the sense that
the acceptance condition at the end is
that you accept the tree if there
is a an execution that is successful
right exactly like neter
machine yeah okay so something that is
is nice about this this model is that
you sorry I was want to say is that you
get the good properties that you have
for automat right so you you can decide
containment you can decide equivalence I
mean there are many nice algorithmic
properties actually in a model that is
more General than than word of T and
actually it's a nice it's a nice way to
represent our problem because of the
foll so think about we have the previous
query we have the relations and the
answer and we are going to represent
this by using a tree automat so how do
we do this first we have this idea that
the values that we are Quantified
somehow they need to be anonymous
actually we don't care about this value
when we are counting we care about this
value when we are checking whether
something is in the answer right so
let's say that we we we we use this
symbols is r four star and R five star
so we are we are saying okay we don't
care about these guys here right and we
do the same for all the values that
should be considered as Anonymous for
example this W is something that is in
the answer but it's not in the answer
here so we are going to have all these
Stars here yeah would you need to
about exactly we need to care about that
and the way that we are going to do this
is by using the transition of the autom
I will show you that in a second this is
very important yeah obviously if you
just keep this I there is no way that
you can count right but the automata is
going to take care of that yeah so in
the automata this is going to be the
alphabet because we will be constructing
trees where we have this symbol that
somehow say okay this is a tree that
tells you that this tle should be in the
answer okay I will show you in a second
how it works and then the states are
going to be the real tles actually
because we need somehow to say okay when
when we're constructing this there is
it's possible to join the elements that
are in
the there is a way to generate this
where I'm doing the right joints right
okay so the states are going to be all
the tables that I have here okay so in a
second I will tell you how this works so
suppose for example we have the answer
for six so in that case actually a
witness for this is this tree here
actually this is a well construct tree
where we say R 46 and I'm doing the
joint with this in the value four also
the joint here with the value four and
here I'm taking one I'm doing the joint
with one here so this is a well
construct tree but this is not what we
are going to consider what we want is
something like this we would like to say
this is going to be the tree because why
I want to do this because I want to
count four six only once right so the
problem here is that if you think about
4 six there are different ways to
generate this right and I don't want to
count all of them I just want to count
only once this 4 six actually so the way
that I'm saying that is saying okay this
is a structor that I want to say that
represent this tle 4 six this is the
values that I'm using and the states of
the automaton are the one that are
taking care that I'm doing the joints in
the right way yeah and I will tell you
in a second how right but remember that
then for first six we are going to have
something like this for first seven
we're are going to have a seven there
only one three that represent this guy
not several and for five eight only one
tree right we are going to have five
here and eight here right it's not like
we are going to have several trees we
want to count this only ones okay so how
this works is as follows you say okay
what should be the the starting State
should be the relation that we have here
because this is the the root of the tree
right so we are going to say let's
assume that we assigned this state R of
4 six and then the transition is going
to take care of the joint so the
transition is going to say if I am in
state R of 46 and this is the symbol
that I'm reading so this is a valid one
because I have the same value of for
here right so I'm not going to have a
transition that says R of 4 five r five
star because this is not a valid way to
think about how to to produce a witness
for this guy right so I'm just going to
say okay in this case if I have these
two guys right then I will assign states
to this to the children that somehow
show you a witness for this for for the
uh for the uh that that this tble here
is an answer to the query right so I'm
going to assign five of 41 and T of 43
again actually I'm doing the right
joints here because I have the value
four here and the value for there right
so and assign this States when I assign
this one actually in this case there is
a simple rule that says well if I am t43
and I have this I'm reading this symbol
here this is something acceptable for a
right and in the other side this is
important one I assign this state like s
of
41 and what you do here is okay you have
a rule and here I have only one children
so you can have also rules of this form
if you have three children you will have
three Estates right uh so what I'm
saying is okay if I have I'm reading
this symbol here and in this state I
have to go to some state where I'm doing
the right joint actually and the right
joint here is this one here right
because here I have to join with the
variable set so there I'm taking taking
care of that right and I'm saying okay
this is one of the possibility I'm not
going to have for example this U of 258
actually there I'm not going to put that
rule
right okay so you do that you assign
this and then you have a rule that says
that this is this is consistent so you
think about this actually what you are
going to do at the end is that for every
answer you are going to have only one
tree that represent the answer and the
states and the transition take care of
this is a well construct tree right so
what is the problem actually that we can
reduce to is the problem of count the
number of trees with four nodes that are
accepted by the tree automat right so
produce that tree automaton and now give
me the number of trees of the Tre with
four nodes that are accepted by this
tree automat if you can count that
actually you will be able to count the
number of answers to the conjunctive
query yeah why four not do we need no no
no this in this case sorry in this
particular case because you have four
notes here actually in the three yeah
but the the problem is I mean you didn't
construct that it would only work for
trees of this kind oh just for we're
considering Clic queries right so you
have a joint tree this joint tree is
going to have K notes and aut doesn't
enforce
sket enforce the skeleton of the tree
which the sket the tree just see how
many nod it no no it doesn't have that
actually but the way that it's
constructed it cannot generate for
example in this case a tree with five
nodes
right enforce enfor so you don't need
the Restriction of four nodes no but you
need to yeah actually you are right
actually you could say yeah you're
absolutely right if you think about
trees that are accept yeah and this yeah
would Point actually in this case
actually you could say count the number
of trees that are accepted by the
automat because the automaton is
Contracting in a way that you can accept
just trees of size four yeah you're
right
yeah okay so I have very little time so
let me show you this this connection
then for troman there is this problem
actually that is the problem of given a
tri tomaton or the alphabet 01 this is
not very important simply the problem
and a number of n you want to count the
number of trees such that t belongs to L
subt is accepted by the the tree
automata and and tomon and and the
number of nodes of T is n actually this
is the problem of counting and this you
could call it the the sharp T8 problem
so this problem uh okay since I have
like three
minutes yeah so uh and I missing the
whole idea how you do this this problem
is related I will do it here otherwise I
will have to keep like one million
slides
uh um this problem actually is related
with a more basic problem which is the
same but for non-deterministic finite
autom right you given a nondeterministic
fin automat you're given a length n and
you are asking how many words of length
end are accepted by the automat right
this problem is a hard problem RP
complete this problem also is a Sharpie
complete obviously because you can I
mean the word automat a special case of
tre automaton and if you if you uh the
type of reduction that you have between
this problem and what are called parimon
which is a way to it's a way for
counting problem to represent many to
one reduction but in particular it tells
you that if you get a good approximation
algorithm for one of them you will have
it for the other so what we did in our
work was first to think about how to
construct a fully polinomial randomized
approximation scheme a good
approximation scheme for this problem
actually so uh the were only known quasi
polinomial approximation scheme so there
is a way actually that I wanted to show
you how to do this and the cool thing
about this is that it uses the
techniques that we presenting in the
previous part of the tutorial right so
you you you you have to construct an
estimator and for this estimator okay
and and you have a confident interval
that you can create from this estimator
and for this estimator actually you have
to do sampling there is a way to do it
and at the end you have to use hefting
inequality to to to bound and to to
finally prove that what you are getting
is a good approximation algorithm and uh
then we did the Second Step that was to
go to this counting for Tre tomaton is a
non-trivial extension it's I mean
requires uh it's essentially the same
schema that we are using there but
requires all the techniques and from
there you can get the the result that we
wanted to obtain which is this result
that tells you that you have some
polinomial time
approximation scheme a randomized fully
fully polom randomized approximation
scheme for the problem of counting the
number of answer to an acli quare right
and this three automata what I'm showing
you this construction also works for
queries of bounded to with of bound the
hyp to with actually so you also get the
results for those classes of queries
okay so let me jump to the last part of
my tutorials which are the open problems
uh okay I have like one
million don't don't
look
yeah I'm estimating
with yeah okay s okay let me okay so the
final results actually I can put the
okay I was too ambitious actually right
but you keep asking and asking actually
right okay so these are the two results
I was mentioned finally that the sharp
ta that meets a fully binomial
randomized approximation scheme and that
the then that the from from there it's
possible to conclude that you also have
the same results for the conjunctive
queries right for asically conjunctive
queries this is very
important okay so let me tell you about
research questions uh and this don't
worry will make sense given all that we
saw in the
tutorial so I think the the first like a
big research question here is that
development a general theory for
estimating for estimation in query
optimization really there is no like
something that you you and I'm cting
this paper because this is an attempt to
do this there some nice results there
but the questions are like this like
which estimator should be used given a
budget right I have a budget to compute
the qu right and actually even what is
an appropriate notion of budget but you
define a budget and you are saying okay
I would like to know what is a good
estimator what I mean how to do this in
general right and in particular what are
optimal estimators if that notion could
could be defined so these are I think
interesting questions it's important to
understand for which relational algebra
operators and aggregate it is possible
to develop sampling techniques with good
strong hopefully
guarantees um some of the techniques are
used in practice actually they show good
results in practice but sometimes you
don't have guarantees right or have weak
guarantees actually so you would like to
know that and also and and well in
particular to develop very efficient
algorithm to compute this this estimator
right this is an important thing and
also to understand the complexity of
computing such estimators and I'm here
I'm talking about finding grain
complexity I think be a lot of
interesting work trying to to produce
like um lower bound concrete lower
bounds for these estimators right um
the other thing is also understand for
which relational alberatos and aggre
Aggregates is not possible to develop
sample techniques with the strong
guarantees I think this is also an
important question actually to
understand when you cannot do
it no I well well you could say
uh well even for joint queries right I
mean like if you have joint queries and
you are considering combined complexity
you really don't have actually right
because in in that in in in in that case
actually you know from from the the
hardness of the counting problem and the
empty hardness of the decision problem
actually that you cannot do efficient
approximation
right U but again actually this is like
the proof requires to have like large
long yeah queries actually so we need to
understand this better actually right
and and and even in the case where it's
not possible actually what kind of
guarantees can be provided actually I
think it's an important question
actually to understand
that uh and actually something that uh
well I was listening to talks actually
this week something I think it could be
very interesting is to try to understand
the whether this I mean whether this
sample techniques can be used for some
fundamental tasks for K relation right
when we have semi Rings actually I think
there are lots could be lots of
interesting probably I mean they have
been used actually it's just that I
don't know about that or or for example
for the logic with semi ring semantics
that's something I learned this week
that the work from from gradal actually
it could be very interesting to see what
kind of things you can do with these
techniques and the last problem and this
is just something I like actually just
but it's a very concrete problem is like
we have word automat then we have Tre
automat then the next problem is like to
count for context free grammars right so
we have a context free grammar we want
to count the number of words accepted by
a context free grammar this is a hard
problem but you want to know where there
is an approximation right uh there is a
quasi polinomial time approximation
algorithm by Canan and all people not
clear at all where this admits a fully
bomal randomized approximation scheme
seems to be very hard problem actually
but I think it's a cool problem so a
very concrete
one okay
thanks oh yes I I want to come back to
my question from all the way in the
beginning my my intuition which
completely wrong says that these kind of
problems for example in in like for the
first bullet um
they actually become easy under back
semantics is is
this because because much of the
difficulty under set semantics comes
from eliminating these duplicate
results right and in and in back
semantics you can
just actually you are right if you
consider conjunctive queries and the
back semantics and you want to count the
number of answers it will be the same as
counting without existential quantifiers
actually you're right it's just
Dynamic yes you're right you're right
yeah so this is this is definitely the
theoretically interesting case but but
maybe it also makes sense to at some
point make something that gives you an
overview of set and back semantics such
that this is also communicated to the
world if it's
true I think
it's so does the algorithm says
something about the data complexity Sor
the data complexity which alith the FP
algorithm you have because this is more
about combined complexity right so it
it's it says it's polinomial can it give
you in terms of data complexity kind of
a better exponent let's say something
that we know that is polom it's not
going to give you a better exponent
right the the algorithm has a i large
exponents actually so yeah if you fix
the the query so some part of this is
going to be fixed is not going to give
you a better
complexity um but I will have to think
more about that yeah yeah it's good
point actually like what we get from
there going to be
F yeah something like that you are right
actually something like that but in
terms of in terms of practical
complexity probably will not be faster
right yeah
yeah so the data complex is POL time for
everything
yeah yeah but it's just whether this
algorithm could provide something is
faster than the usual just the usual
algorithm that you use for
fix my basic confusion is exactly the
framework of so the DAT complexity for
anyl the combin complexity of
any is
po but if you remove Conex then you you
prove that it's no longer time and then
you prove that you
can it's Asic requ but without the
requirement of being
yeah I'm
happy more
questions okay that was a long week so
[Applause]
let's enjoy the weekend and I think we